clips clips clips clips clips clips not
just the clips in my hair guys we have a
clips channel watch our clips we have a
clips channel we have a clips channel
you can see us you can watch our entire
show no but you know what you really
should do is like if you have a friend
you're like i wish they listened to
trash juicers so we could talk about it
send them the clip get them in with the
clip they're gonna love it and by the
way the clips channel is great you want
to keep watching the full thing but you
want to go back you want to remember
what were the highlights like our
channel subscribe to our channel and
share with your friends so that they can
also get sucked into the trash tuesday
world that is your home join the
dumpster
hi slugs today's episode is so good i
can't wait for you to listen to all the
mean things annie says to me and to lisa
lampanelli um you guys come see me on
the road i'm really excited these shows
are coming up so soon i'm coming to
portland new york city and san francisco
and the shows are selling out get your
tickets now and if you love this outfit
sleepover by esther.com i
can't take it off my body i was mean to
esther and to the queen of mean they
call me the princess of mean i will be
on the road again i love it i never want
to leave i will be at
comedy works in denver october 14th
through 16th i'll be in san antonio
texas at laugh out loud comedy club
october 22nd through 23rd houston texas
at skankfest it's sold out
um house of comedy in plano texas
november 11th through 14th and i'll be
doing the irvine improv december 2nd and
a lot more
austin texas december 9th through 11th
check it all out on annieletterman.com
shows and you can get my merch 32 do not
buy my merch on any other website except
mine
[Music]
i give them my full name my screen name
everything to follow me on and i work
the system
yeah but you want to know what's weird
though like i give everyone my real name
which is not lamp enough yeah and the
only people who know i'm lisa lampanelli
are nurses giving me like
colonoscopies i only get recognized as a
celebrity from some humiliating
medical procedures that i have to have
oh you're iron deficient are you the
comedian well you know so i think it's
your fault for losing weight i do your
body is so
pretty a physical transformation they
don't remember it it was pretty funny
how that literally stopped me from
getting recognized and i loved getting
recognized i was such an attention [ __ ]
yeah and so when i first did celebrity
apprentice i was recognized everywhere
because it was a network show and then
after that i lost all the way and
changed my hair and it's like no more i
forget your [ __ ] deal with non-fans
crazy that you did celebrity apprentices
we're one degree away from trumpy i'm so
curious what your perspective like what
what what why is it hot no no it said
horrifying horrifying so disgusting
really what's the hardest first of all
it's the most difficult thing i've ever
done in my life and that's just ego is
that what it was no or the aldi it was
never even really involved it was just
the
amount of work you had to do on those
tasks and i was like passionate because
i wanted to show comics are smart so it
was all the guys on it were smart by the
way there was corolla penn jillette like
two geniuses george takei who's smart
like all these really smart guys the
women were as useful as a tampon at
betty white's house
[ __ ] ridiculous so i'm sitting there
trying to carry the ball for the women
and i'm working so hard and i'm not
kidding
20 hours a day what who six days a week
who are the women there with you
all right
you got this debbie gibson who was fine
yeah but she sang all the time no oh
it's so [ __ ] annoying nobody wants to
stop
terrible then there was this one who was
miss venezuela okay now i don't need
this miss universe energy in the room it
makes me angry because i'm fat at the
time
i
am very jealous very beautiful woman i
can't have it
you guys are lucky i'm so evolved now
that i could be in the room with two
hotties and i'm not talking about these
guys definitely with this outfit i don't
know what vibes are giving off i know
it's all this is a very gender bendery
it is and you know i wish
i've always wished i was a lesbian
because i used to get hit on after shows
by the hottest chicks and i was always
with a guy you know i've been married
twice i like boys
not anymore really because dead from the
waist down officially no one you're not
borrowing tampons from betty white isn't
it no there you go let me share
um but i tell you what man it's it's a
very weird thing this whole apprentice
i'm so glad it's behind me i stayed
until the final four
i just was on every episode yeah i did
watch it
yes me and her were the team oh my gosh
and she here's how i did that
she's talking about idiot women and
you're like i'm our biggest fan no
actually aubry was the smarter
she and i were the smart ones let me
tell you about aubry this is how she
really knew how the game worked i didn't
i came on this is me
oh my god it sounds like so much fun
it's [ __ ] terrible anyway she knows
how to game she knows how to team with
people she's a little she's a hot little
scammer yeah she was in uh making the
band making the band
she's on and she kept being convinced
because lisa me and you are gonna be in
the top two we're gonna fight it out in
the finale and this is how i'm i'm just
smarter than uh in the ways of the world
possibly so i just said dude we are not
famous enough to win
we're going to make it to the final four
because we're the smartest women but
dude we don't have a hope of winning all
we can do is align ourselves with the
two most famous people who are arsenio
hall and clay aiken which that is the
saddest thing i've ever heard that those
were the most famous people
i will say something lisa i do believe
you manifested that i do believe when
you gave yourself the self-limiting
belief that you guys couldn't go all the
way up yes because the reason audrey
o'day is so good
audrey i don't know her i don't i'm
sorry i know she was the most talented
dancer i've ever seen in my life on
making the band on one well
yeah
but
she's delusional and that's how she's
made it through reality shows you are
someone who works on merit and tries to
be the best you can be yes she knows you
just fake that [ __ ] the way that you
dress for the well actually sexuality
you want
she actually the thing about her was
it's come out in public so i don't have
to keep my secret anymore but that she
was effing don jr
and what i love is that she came right
out with it but she was like so in love
with him it was super super sad and i
was just like that's not going to work
out either so i was right about a few
things yeah yeah you know you watched it
all go down it was insane but
they
oh and that came out afterwards well she
came out when trump was running for
president right i think
which was pretty cool
but trump was like literally never even
involved with the show like he would
show up to give you the task
then he would come and judge you oh
right and by the way i've told this
story but you guys are gonna love it
because probably not on air i've ever
told it okay
every time he would have a boardroom he
would always compliment all the women in
the room i mean one at a time right so
every week and of course at the time i
wasn't the great beauty you see before
yeah i was a battle axe with like 250
pounds you know bad hair extensions the
whole nine i wasn't his type yeah
[ __ ] well no no girl there's only one
bad hair extension in this room
baby
so i'm in the room and i figure he's
never gonna compliment me so he's always
saying stuff like theresa
you look beautiful today
he literally said aubry you get more
attractive with every week then one week
i sort of got out of nowhere he's like
lisa and i'm like oh my god it's my turn
and he goes lisa
doesn't teresa look beautiful
and i'm like i am in the room like throw
me a bone but did you get treated more
like a man yes which i got more
respect from him yeah look at i was
always like a guy in comedy yeah that's
why i think i was always very lucky i
came up before there was a ton of women
comments that was like joan rivers
roseanne and then i kind of came on this
scene you were like no one else yeah
probably and i was just like you know
what i kind of
entered at the right time was a dude on
stage yeah i had this standard of every
six seconds of punchline like i don't
tell story i'm now i do but i wouldn't
tell long stories so i think it was uh
you know i got pretty lucky yeah but
yeah it was always the guy you're very
talented and amazing oh my god it was so
good
come on
wait i can't believe so you witnessed so
how did you get successful
i was gonna say esther's only a girl on
stage that's the only place well this is
where you see this mission a skirt is on
stage it's so true well that's what's so
funny about like the whole thing of how
i even came you came on my radar was
obviously crazy ex-girlfriend yeah so i
am so not familiar with any comics like
i literally felt like when i started
comedy i had never watched stand-up
before just the roasts and things like
that in the dean martin days before you
guys were born
so what happened was then
i stopped comedy i i retire and there's
all these girls doing comedy but it
feels like watching homework
i felt like all got it oh no no no it's
not entertainment for you no it's like
you're taking notes and [ __ ]
so i see you on this crazy ex-girlfriend
i'm like this is terrific oh boy do i
love this show because i'm obsessed with
it so i've just first penis i saw is my
literal favorite song of all time i did
a ballroom dance to it anyway oh my god
very badly
so i just out of nowhere look you up
and you're a comedian i said holy [ __ ]
we all are surprised when we find it out
shocked we're like weird
yeah and i was like
and i'm not one to ever ask for things i
have very big problem asking for help i
do everything myself but i just have to
tell her she's so [ __ ] funny and i
love her on that show and then you were
so nice to say oh my god i'm a fan
whether you're lying or not that's fine
i couldn't believe that you had messaged
me i was like is this like a scam i was
shocked too honestly i was like i
thought i was a little more upper alley
to be honest
i was like i think i'm getting catfished
like but obviously like i just because
i'm just we're like we're all such fans
of yours
well you want to know something no i i'm
a clearly a big talker i mean i'm an
over sharer so i apologize well we we
are good okay give me a break i
literally
throughout my whole career it's 30 years
and now three years retired i have no
perspective on if anyone knows who i am
so i will basically dm people just kind
of if i love their work like i've been
watching of course obsessed with hacks
watched it twice already read the pilot
three times
and i was just like paul downs probably
doesn't know me or give a [ __ ] and never
heard of me probably i'm just going to
tell him i love the show and it made me
cry oh my god i'm a big fan of yours i
have i've always said to my manager i
have no perspective like who am i as
famous as i go am i more famous than
nick apollo and she's like oh yeah i go
am i less famous than jeff ross she's
like no and i don't know where i like i
never know also with millennials because
i'm kind of the world's oldest
millennial because i'm woke af yeah i
feel like
who the [ __ ] would even like me like i
have such horrible self-esteem so now
i'm working on that and the fact that
you answered me back i was like yes girl
we're friends i know what's gonna happen
to you is you're gonna flatter your way
back into comedy
please you know all the people watching
flattering and they will do anything you
wanna comedy it's like i was asked i
think nikki glazier asked me last week
on her podcast like oh my god like do
you miss it i'm like oh which part
the part about the no sleep the travel
endlessly the no real connections with
people or animals or nature no i don't
miss a [ __ ] thing it's like you get
to retire
but you guys are doing great you're in
it i want to be i want to die on stage
like that guy tomorrow what guys
oh you mean like you literally had a
heart attack on such everyone's laughing
you're right that was at a roast at the
friars club in the 40s or 50s and
georgie somebody he just totally died on
stage yeah there's somebody if i know
that happened to him by the way some
guys went up and did more roast jokes
about the dead body which i think that's
yeah
absolutely so yes do you think some of
your
feelings of like looking at the comedy
as like a hard thing and something you
don't want to do anymore just not like
aligned with your piece has to do with
the fact that you were aligned with the
roasts and it was kind of a more
negative
no because everybody was so positive
about you know i was sort of almost
grandfathered into you're allowed to do
comedy like you want right in that camp
well there was no canceled culture
before i retired like it didn't exist
yet that was that's happening was that
on purpose no no i mean i had a plan for
five years like the story is like when
my father got really sick i noticed that
not doing comedy i was much more joyful
like even just taking care of him so i
was like like wiping my dad's ass was
more fun than performing like not even
just the performing though i like the
performing part because it was cute but
just the lifestyle was not yeah so it
was just noticing my life and how much i
didn't like it yeah right and then i was
like i'm out of here after i saved
enough money because i do not
i don't do things lightly i made a real
plan i'm not sure i could live made sure
i didn't have to work so i said okay
this is good it's a it's literally how
it's supposed to yeah yeah and now
esther which part do you relate with
then yeah yeah i'm sorry realizing you
hate comedy like oh no no no no pattern
though you're doing that's my pattern
but i'm so like that lifestyle of like
even when i first started like staying
out till 2 a.m at open mics and stuff i
was just like how is this the career
that i'm like going into because i love
to like be in bed at nine like it just i
don't drink like it just
it is there are things about the
stand-up comedians lifestyle that are
hella inconvenient if you're like a baby
if you're responsible as responsibly
yeah i don't want to call her
responsibly an adult because
well i remember years ago there was a
comic who only he was uh kosher and what
those the hasidic jews who they who they
turn off the lights
he literally had a career as a comedian
but he could only perform like till
sundown on a friday so you can make it
that's true i think so if you do shows
at 2pm yeah you actually can because
doug benson does that he does it at 4
20. he used his potheadness
to make his show easier for him because
really the truth is i would assume he's
burnt out he smokes a lot of weird sure
he's tired and he's older he probably
doesn't want to like be up late but you
can use like your like brand is that
you're lazy so that's funny is that
really my brand wow
i like to lay down yeah you do enjoy a
baggy sweat suit
so much you do love that so addicted
which is so funny because you little
skinny girls who are so adorable
you just have the baggiest clothes and
it's just a shame you got to let them
know just that's come on air that beaver
wait you know that reminds me it is
airing yeah it gets it you get bv by too
much tight there was a there is a
comedian that i don't want to say his
name in case this is this is like an
inappropriate joke but he had this joke
that's that was
girls in the
uh girls in the midwest when they take
their clothes off their bodies look so
much better but girls on the coast when
they take their clothes off their bodies
look worse because it's like and it's
it's actually true like when i lived in
illinois and i didn't know how to dress
like i dressed like [ __ ] so i like had
things cutting in places that didn't
need to cut in yeah so then if i took my
clothes off you'd be like oh why were
you doing that but now like if i'm like
doing an event like i can flatter myself
and then it would look worse without
clothes it's so bad like i hate that you
know it's just you know with the weight
struggle and the
issues
yeah but dude i'm like constantly
working on it it makes me so mad that
i'm 60 years old and i still don't have
my food [ __ ] under control i get the
weight loss surgery lose the weight okay
gained a little weight in covid
literally seven pounds and i want i mean
i don't know
dude and it's like just
like yourself the way you are that's
such an easy sentence but i just am like
oh suppose it gets worse suppose it
spirals i gain all that weight back well
basically my stomach's so [ __ ] small
i can't get anything down
so what am i worried about but it's
literally going i've become the sort of
spokesman for this bariatric surgery
what surgery did you get uh the sleeve
where they just basically make your
stomach really small and it stays that
way yep oh well some people stretch it
out
some people stretch it out with eating
too much and i just i haven't done that
can i ask a question do you
do you think because i always think of
like weight loss surgery that it's like
an amazing thing it's like incredible
people's lives however
it's kind of like did you read zen in
the art of motorcycle maintenance where
they kind of talked about um because
it's just about people that are going
cross-country it's a lot of philosophy
and stuff but people that drive
cross-country on their motorcycles and
one guy's wife flew out to meet them and
it's just such a difference when you
like when you go through the country and
you're seeing yourself get to a place
rather than kind of getting there
abruptly it's like your whole identity
is still around being an overweight
person and then all of a sudden you wake
up and it's like this thing has changed
but it's like then you have to work on
well you are your identity on every show
i do if you don't work on that emotional
stuff first don't bother getting it yeah
so basically i've been getting therapy
since i was like 25
and i'm like oh my god i got to work on
why the why is important the how isn't
the how is and also it is a real
adrenaline hit when you lose 90 pounds
in nine months it feels really great
that you're going down like a size a
week but then it's like oh
you got to stay there and then what do
you do with the feelings because i
always ate emotionally
i've never drank i've never smoked pot
i've never like i just don't have a
taste for anything and i'm like oh my
god what do you do oh you have to feel
them yeah so you go to shopping yeah
because at the time it seems harmless
enough because you're rich and because
you're going down in sizes so i have to
right and it's like oh now what do you
do so basically the last three years
since comedy oh and also you medicate
with achievement right which never fills
the hole i mean i don't care how many
radio cities or roasts or specials you
do
nothing fills the hole
this is amazing this is great please
keep going because i'm like where's the
i'm i'm there is i need no solution kill
yourself
esther you're all messed up yeah what
helps you
better help legitimately what helps you
better help yeah thank god you guys
better help is not a crisis line and
it's not self-help it is professional
counseling done securely online where
you can send a message to your counselor
anytime and get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions all without ever
having to sit in a comfortable waiting
room and this service is available for
clients worldwide and they have licensed
professional counselors who are
specialized in depression stress anxiety
relationships sleeping trauma anger
family conflicts lgbt matters grief and
self-esteem and anything you share is of
course confidential and we want you to
start living a happier life today and as
a listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp help dot com
trash tuesday
you know that feeling when you stumble
upon a piece of clothing that is just
like so perfect for you you don't even
know you needed it but now that you have
it you feel like you can never live
without it yep that is how i feel when i
use stitch fix freestyle
stitch fix is here because your your
style isn't one size fits all it's about
what suits your body what suits the
moment so why not shop at a store that's
personalized to your style and size yeah
and then you get the people can do it
for you we're introducing stitch fix
freestyle which is a shop built just for
you stitch fix freestyle is your trusted
style destination where you can discover
and instantly buy curated items based on
your style likes and lifestyle whether
you're looking for a brand you love or
to try a new one at stitch fix freestyle
you can shop a range of over a thousand
brands personalized to your size and fit
with styles for workouts to work wear
for lounging around the house and for a
night out on the town stitch fix
freestyle has clothes for any occasion
plus there's no subscription required
and they offer free shipping returns and
exchanges you guys can get started today
by filling out your style quiz at
stitchfix.com
tuesday the only quiz i've taken in the
past 20 years and i loved it that's
stitchfix.com tuesday to try stitch fix
freestyle stitchfix.com
tuesday
no you know what it is i am literally
okay so i'm talking a life coach last
week
and i'm saying to her you know because
i've been working on this so much i go
dude i go and i was in a moment of
despair which we all go through and i'm
smart enough to just cry it out i'm like
you know what you can't stuff the
feelings yeah i'm not you gotta go
yep so i'm crying and i go i just don't
know i have nothing that fills the hole
and i'm just and she was oh my god
that's i'm so sorry you feel that way
and out of nowhere i don't even want to
cry but like my two little rescue dogs
start barking like crazy run to the door
i think somebody's out there no one is
and she goes i think you just heard a
couple things that they made their
voices known they fill the hole
partially i'm like you know what you're
right so i found that like
the little hobbies i have in retirement
like the podcast i'm doing or the
writing sessions with these two comics
that i help
my two dogs my friends my family i'm
like it's starting to kind of fill up
one corner of that hole but damn you
gotta really cobble together a life that
connects with people nature something
right but it's like being grateful
for the things that you have like
noticing that you did have all those
things around you and especially when
you have this huge hole of this i mean
yeah even if you're connecting or not
connecting on stage it's a huge
like it's a lot of people it's a lot of
things and then to go to like a quiet
space that's gotta your brains gotta
start really going well the fact is they
say that you know i said i had obviously
retired publicly on stern because i was
like that's where people are going to
pay attention and take me seriously and
leave me alone
and um dr drew had heard it and he asked
me to come on his show and i said to him
i want i don't even think i was ever a
comedian and he's like what do you mean
i said i think i just wanted to connect
and i didn't know how other than that
and he goes i bet there's so many comics
that that applies to and i'm like i was
just trying to find people to connect to
and why not lock a bunch of people in a
room and make them listen
so wow well i really relate to what
you're saying about like having to like
build a fulfilling life around you and
like that includes all these different
like levels of things because last year
i i really had like this mental
breakdown where i was like oh my god i
like achieve my goals and like i don't
feel any different and i'm not fixed and
my problems haven't gone away and
i ended up starting i take lexapro
because like that has that's been a game
changer for my anxiety but
that's also why like i started my
clothing line because i don't even
really make money off of it but it's
like
when i'm so stressed out about other
things i just go to that and it's a
hobby like i never had a hobby before me
never dude you wanna know the word hobby
okay this is ridiculous okay when you're
a comic and you're that motivated and of
course i was just like all in it's like
all i could think about yes i didn't
even read the paper like i just [ __ ]
did comedy like that's what it was live
it's really exciting
what's next it's so stupid to have every
hobby that's stupid well so you retire
and you're like i don't knit i don't do
what looks like a hobby so what easter
of last year of this year
i'm bemoaning the fact that i don't have
hobbies and my niece like out of nowhere
just goes you have hobbies i'm like no i
don't i've got basically nothing and
she's like um okay so you meet with your
friends and write you're developing this
you're doing this podcast you're you
have the dogs you have this and she
names like 10 other things i'm like oh
my god i do have hobbies but they just
don't look like anybody's so you think
especially my age like
oh it's so different and weird but i
have to accept that this is what kind of
brings me a little joy yes what is the
definition of a hobby can you look that
up because i'm wondering like because
i've been trying to look at like comedy
as my hobby and money as like an energy
exchange that has nothing to do with
right so i just only do jokes i like i
only do clubs i like i only like i just
choose what i want to do i don't like if
i have to cancel a show because of
something else i try not to cancel but
you know like i just like put my what
whatever i want first what is it
an activity done regularly in one's
leisure time for pleasure
and yeah i've been thinking a lot about
like work i thought about this some girl
dm'd me and i just had a second and i
wrote her back it also means a small
horse or a pony oh
maybe i could get her
hobby horse oh she's my hobby i ride her
um
but so some girl dm'd some girl dm'd me
and asked me she was like because i had
said in some podcast she was like
someone had said you had said something
about someone i told me one of my
professors said something about when you
half-ass something even if you have to
half-ass something do it anyway yes and
what she was referring to was i had a
teacher who a professor had told me even
if you're late just show up to class but
then i would show up with like five
minutes left like i really get that rule
but
i i what she said kind of like triggered
this thought in my head where i was like
you know it's really her perception what
half-ass is and i do this too and it's
like i'll get paralyzed not get work
done not do the things that i that will
lead me to my goals because i'm worried
about doing it perfect doing it at like
the
you know like at this level i've never
even seen anyone work out it doesn't
even exist i've never worked there so
then i'm like holding myself to this
yeah perfect thing and instead just look
at it like half ass is the full ass and
then just happily do a little bit of
whatever i need to do well because i
have to ask to you because i can already
tell because the same as me
half-assed i always said half my effort
is worth two other people right full
effort so we're just bad asses i'm so
[ __ ]
johnny lawrence from kobakai i'm like
that's how i [ __ ] i i'm all in all
the time and
what i that was how comedy was right now
what i do is i'm like okay
the end product really if you said to me
right now because this came up at lunch
just now somebody goes what do you want
i go and literally i didn't have to
think it just fell out and i was shocked
i just go peace
and like holy [ __ ] so if i look at
everything in my book which by the way i
love the fact that it's almost empty i'm
so the opposite of joan rivers i worked
my way out of that
where i look at it and i go oh my god
does this bring me peace
yeah it's like more you're more condor
or however you say it your life like
yeah did you do her no i don't believe
in her because i don't think she'd get
rid of everything i follow the
minimalist rule which i just did their
podcast yesterday it's spectacular and
it's this thing about if you want your
life to be better
you don't add to it you subtract from it
right so basically subtracting the wrong
husband the wrong career comedy for me
at that time you know subtracting the
wrong friends that's why the pandemic
was a little bit good for me in the way
of that oh didn't it declutter
friendship yes so i go wow every time i
try to add more it doesn't work but
subtracting works and then the right
stuff appears because then also you just
have the things that you love around you
you know so it's like you're just only
seeing things that motivate you and make
you feel good yeah and have the people
around that i notice now in my life
nobody needs me more than i need them
because i was always the one who helped
and fixed and paid for everything and
was like well i make the most in the
room so i have to pay for the dinner
that's like not making them feel
anything
it's enabling them to not make money
until yeah it's not good so i was trying
to help them
but really what they needed to do was
heal themselves so helping and healing
is two different things that's their job
but even now i'm like wow this is really
good to but it keeps me in check now
i'll let it go um i'll make mistakes and
then i'll go pull it back
pull it back ask what you need for help
don't help too much because that's their
journey right so it's all in it i i love
where i'm at now but it has to get
better like it just has to keep getting
better i can't let myself slide and it's
work it sounds like okay i that's what i
i always thought like
race to be finished with something and
then you'll have peace like i never i
thought like do this do this this and
then and then everything will be good
but it's actually like the journey the
work like there is no like finish line
where you rest everything in your life
takes work and that's like a part of the
good life or whatever like
that realization is was has been very
hard
but if you only do the things that you
like right if you only like choose
things that are like aligned with what
you really really like then it's like
not
it does it's not working i have a friend
who
my friend hannah feidel wrote all these
movies she's got like a deal with fx she
she had a show called a teacher on fx
she's like so she's always writing
something and i asked her once i was
like how do you write like how do you
sit down and write she's like i love it
i was like oh
yikes
that resonates big time because i'll
tell you something
in the past few years people that on the
podcast or tv or whatever would go to me
um
what do you miss about comedy and i
literally can't think of anything except
i remember when i started
i started in connecticut i've said i'm
not going to be seen in a city until i'm
good then that's probably why i took off
because i was never looked at as an open
mic or in new york or l.a so i remember
being in connecticut and we would all go
to the diner after the open mic and like
trade jokes and have fun with it and i'm
like oh my god when i look at my life
now i'm like oh my god i just recreated
the one part of comedy that i loved
which was sitting around writing jokes
having fun with these guys and that's
what you're doing your podcast well well
no we actually go really deep what we do
is i help them with their comedy but
what we do on the podcast is i notice
these two guys it's these the podcast
called losers with a dream
and what happened was i noticed they're
straight guys
who are millennial age but they're not
bro
they like literally are masculine but
talk about such deep [ __ ] that i was
like this is a podcast guys and of
course i shoehorn my way on so i'm like
oh my god this is the thing you have to
put vulnerability with humor into
straight guy spaces
so they start doing it and i'm telling
i'm not even kidding like i have to
smile right now
every time we do a podcast i'm so happy
it's so much fun
i make them go deep the issues are
really hard to talk about it's like
acceptance vulnerability fear of success
um alcohol isn't like dying
[ __ ] dying podcast because one of
their moms died when he was six and the
other ones had many friends die through
alcoholism and things and i'm like why
are my comics right right exactly and
and then i go on and of course i make
fun of them a little bit because i have
to that's my brand and i enjoy doing
that and they love me and then i like
kind of coach them i'm like dude
how am i going home smiling at 60 years
old having millennial guys in my life
who are actually vulnerable
a miracle they're cute yeah definitely
that's a part of it
no you're like not for me not for me
right now it just feels so weird that
every time i drive home no honestly this
is what intentional living as you know
you're saying
you look in your book every time you
drive home you go oh my god why am i
smiling with comedy
i i god bless it i love the stage not
much anymore but boy
going to the hotel
going to the [ __ ] airport i would
notice every thursday
i would start to get really bummed
because i'd have to pack
and i'd be like oh my god so you just
start noticing this life is not for me
anymore but
it worked out how it should yeah and how
how did you find these two guys
this was random as f which shows why i
sometimes have to say yes to things
because i'm a big you know how they say
improvers are great because they're yes
ands i've been a no but since the day i
was yeah i if you asked me today let's
go mountain climb i'm like get the [ __ ]
out of here like i don't even have a
mild reaction where i go oh no thank you
i go you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
because i hate everything i just say yes
and then get mad at them for asking i'm
like why the [ __ ] did you put me in this
position that seems appropriate yeah so
what happened was my niece emily my
sister's daughter
she said to me she works at indeed and
she said to me one day she goes you know
i have a friend at indeed and he's
trying to
try comedy he's doing a show can you
come and give him notes
and of course i'm loaded for bear
because i'm like i know this guy's gonna
suck like yeah
so
i do anything my nieces and nephews ask
i'm a big [ __ ] i like to care take so
we go to dinner and i say to him at
dinner i said bo listen man
guaranteed you're gonna suck guaranteed
i won't have anything nice to say but
i'm just telling in advance i tell it
like it is he said no problem
i see him do the comedy this is like two
years ago i'm like oh he doesn't suck
he's a beginner
but i always an ex-boyfriend of mine
once said every open micro has one joke
worth stealing and this guy had a few
so then i say oh let's have a writing
meeting you're actually pretty good
then he introduces me to this guy nick
nick scopoletti
and that's when i noticed they're both
funny and vulnerable which to me i don't
know if you guys date and stuff but like
[ __ ] guys in their 30s when i was
growing up they didn't talk deep [ __ ]
that's why you gotta date guys in their
20s yeah i think so i'm going back to
the teens
they
for some reason they had some feelings
and i've noticed this in my nephews too
which i love
that they
literally we my mom passed away a few
months ago
and yeah thank you and
i noticed they actually teared up and
cried and talked about their feelings
and wanted to plant trees for grandma
and stuff and i'm like
holy [ __ ] they've this generation i call
myself the world's oldest millennial
because i do not relate to 60 year old
[ __ ] everyone in my age group is
worried about their taxes [ __ ] you
how about black lives matter how about
putting people to work how about [ __ ]
not being a douche bag who worries about
your house but how about putting the tax
guys to work i agree they're helping
them they are helping sometimes i'm
wrong
no but isn't it interesting to not
identify with your age group yeah and i
don't try to make myself look younger i
don't have facial surgery i don't like
it for me no you're killing it you look
amazing it's better yeah you are so like
i i do feel like you're a peer of mine
like i just feel like we could sit and
talk forever like i feel like we have so
much in common and she said she mastered
comedy
oh that's true actually i shouldn't say
that
already already but so the podcast is
called losers with a dream i love that
i'll tell you what that's from what was
really as you know i did all the roasts
and things on comedy central so what
happened was i remember
when i we're sitting around trying to
figure out because as you know a title
for a podcast book
special is the hardest thing we have our
own drama oh i'm sure we have episodes
dedicated yes so you understand it's
hard so we're sitting around and i'm
like wow what's this about like you guys
suck at almost everything i'm terrific
i said so what is this and then i
remembered at the rose i don't know if
you ever noticed but i would hit the
whole day as first i'd make fun of
everybody on there and then i'd go but
enough about these losers with a dream
let's talk about pam anderson so i'd
like wrap it up or enough about these
wastes of skin let's talk about so i
said you can have this it's a line for
mine but it really does describe and i
have to admit even me too because
we're all kind of losers because we're
trying to make it work we're trying to
figure out life and i'm in despair just
as much as they are at my age and i'm
like but we do have this dream and
theirs is to become famous to get
married to have children which i love
that men talk about that but mine is
definitely that i'm trying to have a
peaceful life and it's [ __ ] hard like
when you remove so much [ __ ] you gotta
sit with the empty and that's the hard
part
wow that is so cool i love that name so
much i like it who doesn't relate to
that it's so right
um i'm curious like your opinion because
what is your opinion of like comedy
today or if you like or just cancel
culture and like stuff even though i you
know some people say there's no such
thing whatever like what do you think of
all the things that you see happening
because i've been very public about
saying if i've hurt anyone's feelings
like they literally just have to ask me
and i will apologize because i don't
think there's any badge of honor in
dying on your sword of like no i'm a
comic i could say anything and you have
to [ __ ] get my intention i totally in
the old days intention used to be okay
for rickles for me for jeff ross
the audience was so multi-racial because
we had that love for the people we were
making fun of and multi-sexual any
sexuality whatever
now it's not like that anymore so my
feeling is i don't know this is a random
number but if you've tweeted something
in the last seven to ten years when you
should know better that you shouldn't
say the n-word you shouldn't like say
gay jokes or whatever
you could apologize it'd be nice of you
yes you shouldn't be canceled then your
apology should be sincere yeah but i
hate when comics are like no man it's my
[ __ ] art form okay good die [ __ ]
and then you have to come back in the
next life and you be that guy it seems
like such a defense mechanism to be like
that
like do you really need to do that type
of comedy more you know it's like did
you not like it's like
do you have to what is the game here
you're hurting p isn't like i like to
make people happy i really hate i love
doing stand-up because i love the i do
like connecting and i like the exchange
of energy and stuff but it's like
i i mean i i definitely used to feel
more like fear of being canceled and i
think when you have fear of being
canceled you almost like create that for
yourself and it's like being a victim of
some like thing that
it's just people on the internet you
know well i agree and i think what's
funny is like i
didn't notice i didn't know what cancer
culture was and um
then i quit comedy and then a couple
years later it happens and i'm like oh
i just don't think
i would be able to look in a mirror if i
did some of the same type of jokes yeah
which is fine because i'm my only judge
like i whatever anybody else says that's
fine i've i'm probably canceled i don't
care the fact is do i want to die on
that sword no i want to be like the kind
of guy well i'll tell you a story
one of my last few shows i hadn't
announced the retirement yet um i'm
doing jokes and just and you know i hit
everybody in the audience so there's an
old guy i'm doing all my old guy jokes
about he is dying laughing and i always
loved seeing people over 70 at the show
because i'm like oh my god because i'm
going to be 70.
i might actually kill you you might
actually die that'd make me headlines by
the way i get so much more famous
i'm obsessed with cereal we had to stop
eating it because it's filled with sugar
and junk and [ __ ] and it's not good
for you it was a scam
you're supposed to grow up well yeah
it's this is grown-up cereal this is
this is allowing you to bridge the gap
between growing the f up and staying
we're talking about magic spoon with
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in each serving only 140 calories a
serving it's keto-friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free and low-carb and
build your own box the available flavors
to build your own custom bundle are
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry cinnamon cookies and cream and
maple
waffle waffles rule
also you guys were so excited because
they brought back cookies and cream and
maple waffle permanently those flavors
used to be limited edition and now
they're there all the time makes me feel
safe i sleep safer at night
she sleeps late for at night and wakes
up in the middle of the night to eat it
yes
you guys can go to magicspoon.com
tuesday to grab a custom bundle of
cereal and try today and be sure to use
our promo code tuesday at checkout to
save five dollars off your order and
magic spoon is obviously so confident in
their product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked we'll ask some
questions though
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
tuesday and use the code tuesday to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode you know
what i love is neutral oh
dude how much have we been loving
neutrophils look how long my hair got i
do know that your hair is generally
healthier and better
yeah my nails do 30 million women are
impacted by weekend or thinning hair and
if you're among them you're not alone
okay because you got your trash tuesday
slugs and we're here and there's a
solution that you can trust that will
actually deliver results
in a clinical study 86 of women reported
improved hair growth after six months
more than 1500 top doctors recommend
neutrophil as an effective and high
quality solution for healthier hair we
love it
i i just i know i can speak for all the
slugs on the stage today we all use it
and also our lovers use it so it's for
everybody and you guys can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show
by going to nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month's
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time and plus
it's free shipping with every order get
15 off at neutrophil.com
spelled n u t r a f o l dot com slash
trash
but then i did a joke which i'll never
obviously do again and it was about i
mean some kind of special needs thing um
and everybody laughed but i saw the
guy's face just change a little and you
know when you're doing insult comedy and
you realize you really want special
needs and you know what oh no
that would have been a way better story
no but i noticed a shift and i just
you know you kind of shut down
and you know at that time i was working
on myself so much and i just go sir are
you okay and he goes oh no it's fine
it's fine i go i go listen i like you i
want to meet you because i really wanted
to talk to him about it because i sensed
i hurt his feelings
so i said come back with your wife
and he tells me backstage that he i mean
this is before it was popular to adopt
oh you know special needs kids anything
he's like you know it's just a few years
ago or if you when we were really young
we adopted some special needs because
then that kind of hit me the wrong way
and i of course i'm like oh my god i'm
so sorry and he starts crying and i
start crying and we hug no that's
connecting
so i got no problem apologizing to an
individual because first of all he was a
gentleman he didn't yell out he didn't
storm out and he didn't be a little
[ __ ] yeah i'm just honest with you the
ones who [ __ ] yell at you you don't
get an apology i know and also you don't
apologize to a group
if it's an individual right yes but if
on behalf of all gay people a straight
guy oh it's an apology they can suck my
hairy clown okay believe me it's harry
because i'm 60. so listen i'm 38 and on
the same page but um
i
i watch survivor do you watch the show
survivor no but i heard tell about it
okay i love i love the show survivor and
this season jeff probst the host
there's there's um there's a like a
butch lesbian on it young lesbian girl
who's she's probably like 22 maybe she's
i can't she does something really she's
a very incredible either job or she's
studying to do something like very
impressive
and then like really smart girl and then
um there's a man who is married to a
trans woman who just had a baby so like
a trans man i'm sorry a trans man who
just had a baby so he's married to
a
trans yeah a woman woman at this point
right so now but now looks like a man
right who now is has had the surgery
okay gave birth to a kid so
um
but he i guess now i don't i guess i
would i don't know if that makes him gay
or straight i don't really understand
what it is but not my problem not a part
of the story so jeff props the first
when he says come on guys welcome in and
then he says to everyone he goes oh wait
you know what every single season of
this show i've said
hey guys and now i want to ask is it
okay to refer to all his guys now i want
to die when i hear that because i'm like
all right let's not waste time on our
packaging a little far yeah we've got
have we not risen okay but you know
whatever he's asking and uh the lesbian
girl speaks up and she goes i actually
am really fine with it i i actually
like being called a guy like i think
it's it's fine i don't take it as like a
gender thing as much as just a kind of
group thing then the next episode or the
end of the episode they're meeting up
again a couple days later and the the
man who's married to the trans man
says
you know i was thinking about it and i
think i was too tired to do my part
i want to say that it's not okay
but he's not trans so it's like he's
speaking for he's in the world but he's
in the world of trans so i understand it
but it's kind of like the girl and i
mean i guess
i don't know if jeff was uh was asking
her specifically but she was the one
that kind of stood up and it's more her
experience with the gender
right i explained that so it was kind of
like all right dude so now you're
bringing it back up and now jeff's like
all right i'll never say guys again i'm
like
but what i always resented i'm sure
you'll identify with this is when
i would get because back in the day we
didn't have twitter or anything it
didn't exist and if they would write
like i'm so offended at this joke that
joke just joke
you shouldn't [ __ ] on the black
community even though i had huge amounts
of interracial couples
it would always be from a white person
and honestly that's a way of keeping
someone else down a way of keeping
someone a victim a way of saying this
group is too weak
the white savior and i'm like no no no
white savior's here [ __ ] so i'd never
answer those i was just like delete so
yeah it's it's interesting like who we
feel we have to i always say i do i do
make fun of i used to be a special ed
teacher and i and i worked at easter
seals and stuff and i do make i try to
make fun of everyone of course you know
equally and i think it's like including
them it's like obviously how you feel
probably during the roast and stuff it's
like you want to include everyone if
they're in wheelchairs or anything make
jokes like because it's almost like the
absence of that is saying like oh no we
have to treat you precious like it's not
like treating them equally well dude
here's the deal
if what is the biggest prejudice of all
leaving someone out so if you know lisa
lampanelli makes fun of everyone
you expect to be made fun of right so i
i just think feeling pity for someone is
the worst yeah no one wants to be yes we
want empathy compassion no one wants
pity so remember you know some all bets
were always off with me i loved when
deaf people would come because they
always had deaf interpreters and it was
fun to make them say content sign
language yeah
so what was it like uh it's this i'll
show you i was taught it by deaf people
oh my god that's a little bit why is it
molested i know well it's a clip
basically i'm triggered community well
you know how that even occurred that i
know this first of all let me tell you
the handicap story um
this i remember doing new year's eve
down in atlantic city and this gay guy
was in the audience he told me he was
gay when i was asking and he had half an
arm so of course come on i mean not
gonna say he lost it up somebody's ass i
mean come on
it's low-hanging fruits it would be rude
to not say it right so everyone could
always take a joke from me i found that
the people who were uncomfortable were
the ones who feel they have to caretake
others no i was saying it's always the
best to have the best audience is a
person with a disability that's had to
deal with at this point they're so over
that they're above that sort of thing
and the worst audience is the table next
one that's never met them 150 percent
worst audience and they just don't get
it those are the ones you get the notes
from those are the ones you have to
ignore but boy this uh it's just it's
the kind of world in which you have to
not be careful but you have to just go
you know what i can look in the mirror
at the end of the night you know i i
this
horrified me once i've only been
protested three times twice was by the
westboro baptist church because i had a
gay following
and that was fine because i [ __ ]
donated money for every [ __ ] who
showed up it was great
but then i got protested by deaf people
and it honestly did really hurt my
feelings a lot i show up at university
of rochester
i guess they didn't know i made fun of
everybody so they heard me on the radio
not the definitely somebody else yeah
and they heard the death joke well you
really took some liberties probably
because you didn't think they'd hear it
didn't 100
yeah some blind cockblocker with an
extra grind told them
so what upset me was i show up there and
i'm like crying because i'm like i'm
being posted protested by one group and
they don't know i make fun of everybody
so i invited all the protesters into the
show
and at the end they came up to me and
apologized and they were like dude
they're sorry
no they literally said to me they go
we're really sorry we saw through your
show you make fun of everybody we
overreacted and i said as your
punishment or no your payment to me you
have to teach me the death symbol for
context and that's how i learned it so i
think it's once you sit down and talk to
somebody yeah once you freaking hear
their story like that's why i don't mind
an apology and it's just you know nikki
glazier was on
bill mark a few weeks ago and she said
she believes the same thing she'll
apologize to an individual and he was
like no no you shouldn't and this and
that and he's allowed his opinion that's
great but i think we are a little more
open to doing that now and i don't think
there's anything wrong with doing that
right
well it's whatever you want to do it's
like there's no like one telling us
whether we can
you
bobby would you like to say you're sorry
for how you've treated me so badly
i know you guys must have had beef at
some point no we didn't and you know
what's funny about bobby everything that
he's asian i did not know i was going to
your house and i was so happy i was like
this is fancy
oh my god yeah telemorse um i like your
kitty laying white hair thank you no no
no it's the it's the blue oh a smurf
blue it's loaded
i'm so good how are you do you live here
around new york no i'm in connecticut
she loves she's fantastic she went back
into my childhood home you did yeah
that's such a move to buy your family it
was so cute because it's very sweet you
look great oh thank you man honestly she
is why you should take some [ __ ]
pointers from her yeah she's got her
life
he looks cute you freaky friday
you used to be the skinny boy you know
it's so [ __ ] funny [ __ ] i came in
here right and i was like i'm not going
to attack andy letterman
i'm happy with who i am come at me you
can't hurt me me and esther are you
going out of there what are you going to
go
go i'm here no no i can only make fun of
you
assumptions i have of you and i've never
seen the thing
the thing
that's what they call a vagina oh god
i call mine clothes for business it is
so horrifying do you know i have been
celibate
by choice and probably not by choice
since i've been
uh right i got married right after i got
married i became celibate so i think
it's been 12 years are you still married
oh no no no you divorced the guy yeah
but he's the great guy we're still
friends i like him from gotham yeah he's
full and what's so funny about being
celibate dude you guys will see someday
maybe i i don't know if it's your part
of your journey there is nothing better
than not [ __ ] waking up to a uti
not having some [ __ ] jerk there i
know
they don't wash their dick you know what
they have to wash their dick a little no
you're supposed to piss before and after
i get these utis i haven't had one in 12
years you need a bedpan well you know
what else i love not having it's a
pinched nerve in my neck because every
valentine's day i pinched it over my
neck and a uti get the how do you get
that
how do you get that from anal
what's weird i wish i'd experimented
with the anal when i had the chance no
this is never too late this is your time
kind of they sew it up by the way bobby
i just got speaking of buttholes i did
not mean to bring this up that's aaron
we're happy i recently had a colonoscopy
because i turned 60. i'd had one at 50.
they show you pictures now of your
[ __ ] dude mine is [ __ ] awesome
that's a huge deal
it's mine's in blackface it's beautiful
compared to who i don't know i thought i
never saw another one with the inside
though like yeah dude all the way the
[ __ ] does it look like um the magic
school bus
the magic school bus was inside the
it just literally looks like how you
would imagine the most pristine [ __ ]
in the world looks like because she
didn't know
it's unfucked with but from the eating
days you didn't have hemorrhoids no i
got one oh my god
after weight loss surgery it's very hard
to poop and you have to be patient but
i'm not a patient person so i'm sitting
there trying to squeeze it out i mean no
offense but i was like grabbing the
handicap bars and just pushing and
pushing so this thing pops out i've
never had one before that yeah it looked
like a [ __ ]
louisville slugger poking out of my ass
yeah it looked like a [ __ ] speed bag
at a boxing gym
and i'm like this is yeah
yeah yeah
it was just
i don't know how it disappeared either
because i didn't get it cut out i don't
know what happened to it sometimes they
suck back in i think that's what
happened here to say hi i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on yeah this poor
guy we're talking about [ __ ] i like
you in georgia spot you have like a hat
that looks like his hair yeah wait
anyway uh
elise good to see you bobby i'm so can i
just be i mean we've been sincere this
whole time we really have but i'm so
happy for your success because i
remember when we were doing comedy here
yeah you said i was always
really good and i always thought you
know jesus christ he needs more parts on
tv he needs more of this
i say last night
no but you honestly every time i see
someone who i thought was funny years
ago on tv i just cry i'm so happy for
them so dude you're [ __ ] rocking that
[ __ ] and i will give him this he was on
tv when i was about two years old he was
already on mad tv
you've been successful this whole time
you just never you never discussing you
never ever ever
it's it's close for business and let me
say something to you please don't stop
me mommy can i
can i have all three of you can i can i
introduce one last thing you won't ever
remember this but do you do you remember
the exact sketches sometimes that you
did on mad tv no oh see that's a problem
because he did one about something about
like sort of a godzilla type creature
coming in that was my vagina he was
dying i know that sounds like it's asian
misappropriation but you're so [ __ ]
funny
and i just wanted to come down here and
say hello get some compliments i want to
see these two you know what i mean but
yeah
i found out you were coming over i was
really excited because we're old friends
yeah and um please come around some more
i will man you on mine i heard it's
terrific my friends are my buddies on
the podcast nick and bo they're obsessed
with your [ __ ] podcast yeah i would
love so what are you talking about don't
steal our views [ __ ] george is george
she's ours
yeah i'll get george on it all right
he's um he's a real the real deal man
and you don't look fat she's wrong no no
no no no no no look at him
you don't seem naked you don't see him
naked
he is so funny esther there is
how does it feel to be the only two sane
people in this room right now
i never thought i would be the calm one
it feels scary
i'm getting the signal for let's do a
banana break what's that when you dipped
our bananas no oh god
[Music]
our banana break represents like
potassium yes do you know my mother
would always say every week oh my god
you guys want to laugh so hard
every week she leave me her shopping
list and i thank god i saved one on my
messages she's like okay
so i want four table talk pies they were
these little tiny pies no cherry just
blueberry like yelling and
four bananas not too ripe
i got it ma
every week not too ripe for ten years
she said not to ripe so this is for you
my did you [ __ ] big did you die did
you dye your hair blue to be closer to
the blueberry she loved like notice me
mama you have a very good comedy mind i
have to tell you because that was very
good i like it when i can actually
respect the people i'm on the podcast
with because trust me i phoned a few in
nicki glazer i'm just gonna i'm gonna go
you love mickey i gotta get nikki on
this one you gotta start some feuds
nicki you're a [ __ ] oh my god i dare
you to come back at us oh my gosh we're
trying to get our numbers up she
wouldn't she would so cry because no she
wouldn't believe it of course not by the
way i always laughed i just bumped into
rich frost last week he did this little
club near where i live and i was like
this rich voss you know what he used to
do you know how he's so mean off stage
he would come up to me and this is the
beauty of rituals he would come up the
next day and go hey last night you know
i was kidding right
so he'd always like make sure you were
okay and you know what that shows that
he's a little [ __ ] and he's taking
everything personally right dare you no
you're right though you're right yeah i
love you like he's like
but that's that is cute because none of
the other guys i had such a hard time
with all the guys coming up and they
were always really mean and i hated it
and i was just like why can't keep your
comedy to the stage why be being off
stage like i'm such a fan esther would
die if people weren't mean i've said she
like feeds her i know i like i love i
love being roasted teas made fun of
that's like my love language let's put
it this way i admire that quality i will
say that i have said publicly after
retirement i literally could not take a
joke i had the thinnest skin not on the
roast those were fine but offstage and i
was like lisa you were an insult comic
who couldn't take a joke that's like
being a pedophile who can't stand
children's parties yeah it's like come
on it's like you can't take a child to
death it's like come on there's nowhere
for you it's like a porn star who's
allergic to semen
that doesn't like small dicks yeah i
mean so i i just go it's it's
interesting though i really always had a
thin skin when we were just sitting
around at the table so i would just
bring a book and read well that is such
a move to bring a book and read but i
have problems with when you go on the
road
oh what book do you have i'll just start
reading
oh my god i'll read my book what is it
let me hypnotize you you don't know
where
oh i have that i sold it you said i just
kidding yeah she brought my second hand
because i quit comedy she saw all her
comedy books
i have a question when you did the
roasts because i have heard from other
people who've done the roast that like
just i've not people that i know
personally but i've heard like through
the grapevine like some people have been
like left really affected in a bad way
and i'm just curious if you ever had
that experience if it ever bothered you
or was whatever this is how i'm smart
i
wanted to always appear like on camera
as much as possible because you know i
started comedy late i was thirty is that
why you're fat
yeah
yeah i know really eat your way to the
top so i'm sitting there and i always
knew because there's a teleprompter
and you always saw your name being used
but you didn't read the joke so i'm like
okay get ready to look like it's funny
even if it sucks so i would always sit
up you know you sit at the edge of the
chair and you just like oh my god so i
would always get these emails like oh my
god you take it as good as you give it
so i always knew that was the best sport
in the world
so i'm sitting there and somebody asked
me you know do any jokes hurt your
feelings and legitimately honestly it's
roast so probably not
the few times it hurt
was when
it was lazy
so
if a joke is like just a random [ __ ]
horror fat whatever insert woman insult
type here i'd be like geez i'm not even
worth that like it really would be just
like yeah it's like one man try be
creative for me because and but if
somebody writes a good joke about me i
am so [ __ ] happy like artie lange had
the best joke about me i put it in my
book i was like i don't even care i love
this so much
we were doing shatner i think shatner's
roast and hardy was at his most fattest
poor thing yeah the gray skin and he
goes up and he goes if i had a nickel
for every time somebody said hey aren't
you lisa lampada
i
loved it so i said to myself well maybe
i don't have thin skin i just like
people to make an effort yeah
so it just felt insulting if you just
throw a fat joke or an old joke or an
ugly joke your way yeah it's dumb i
didn't do that yeah i literally would
take two months to write a good roast
because i had to usually go last because
they were all [ __ ] and follow me it's
better to go last no it's the worst
because no but i still think it is
because you can you know the best spot
first
because you get it all out of the way
your anger won't be there oh my anger
was always there before i quit comedy i
literally used to because my mother was
a rage-a-holic and bless her my dad
resolved that
yeah i always went to anger and what's
interesting is ever since i retired i've
noticed the anger going away slowly and
coming out of sadness which is what it
actually is
so anytime i see somebody yeah i mean i
still yell but not that percentage but
dude like whenever i hear a story about
somebody yelling in a drive-through or
whatever i go what pain they must be in
because i know it was all painful oh
yeah no you that's the best i feel like
that's such a good way especially with
like trolls and stuff when i was
decluttering and getting rid of two of
my other places and just moved into my
parents and my original house this is
esther's dream it's my dream
she literally how she wants to get rid
of to move into her purse literally like
i go home whenever i can i'm always in
the parents basement i know i have to i
want to live there one day well yeah and
also by the way you just realize you
need very little like in life you don't
need much yes so i found of course i
have 8 000 boxes of my comedy career and
i go you don't need most of this
so i went through and i had printed out
every script 80 times you know while
writing all the drafts
so i found there was at least seven
boxes of stuff
that had nothing on the other side eight
and a half by eleven so i'm like okay
just use these as a printer paper so the
other week i was having a game night
because i'm that chick i [ __ ] love it
and i i love it so much and it's all
gays and they're all under 30. it's
fantastic that's how you're never gonna
[ __ ] i know i gotta keep my
this is what i want for you i'm
projecting this on can you be a guest
and do that
so i take the printer paper out and
we're all like keeping score on these
things and my gay friend bobby who's
half black half white looks at it and
it's like
what
does this mean he goes without the arabs
thank god for the arabs they keep the
jews away
oh my god oh oh thank you muslim for
letting me speak without your permission
what is that i know you remember and he
goes oh my god this is hilarious so
literally it's always a crap shoot what
part of my career is going to come from
oh my god and by the way i know it
sounds
but i literally
when i see that stuff come out
i kind of have to revisit it and mourn
it a little bit and go oh that was the
movie that i wasn't very good in or like
it's a script or oh that was the roast
and that was fun or oh it's a shame that
that didn't lead where i wanted it to
even though that was wrong for me to
want something else so it's very cool
it's very therapeutic yeah yeah i love
like i'm addicted to nostalgia positive
or negative so that sounds really nice
like you're making me want to like keep
everything
even more so like i don't know i just
love that experience but she's like
releasing it too so yeah keep it to then
release because it's like it was just
sitting in these boxes doing nothing
right well then i also was wondering
what are your guys opinion because i
have no perspective we don't say guys
anymore
you [ __ ]
yeah i'm a survivor um
by the way speaking of survivor this is
a horrible joke but i remember a few
years ago years ago um remember the show
the amazing race yeah i think jim norton
said something like what is that a show
about white people oh it's so funny
oh my god they have one too that's like
they have one too that's like the
the greatest race now too where it's
like guys
what's your opinion on this because
again like i said i have no perspective
on if anyone knows who i am
there's a comedy museum the comedy hall
of fame in jamestown new york they had
asked me because that's where lucy was
born lucille ball they'd asked me to do
an interview with them i was so near the
end of comedy i go i can't i can't i
said i'm just so [ __ ] exhausted i
don't want to do it it's like your
holocaust museum
i was like i have such cute comedy
memorabilia that really doesn't mean
anything more to me yes really about my
life and just like the radio city post
or whatever's nice and scripts that
actually were worth keeping like i did a
simpsons i mean that's yes
definitely
should i ask them if they want it yes
lisa oh my god why would you not ask
what's wrong i'm always beneficial i i
always well the worst thing is that they
could say no and that's not even yeah
and then what would yeah how would that
that would it would probably just lead
to grief and sadness if they don't want
it i will i literally have a chill oh
like that is she'll throw she'll take it
put it in a box and then put my parents
down
i love that kind of stuff like one of my
favorite experiences is going to museums
and seeing like other artists work like
not their like work but their things
their workspace and their
products like i went to the
country music hall of fame or whatever
and i saw like casey muskraves like
things from her childhood and then i
went to this amy winehouse exhibit and
saw like her notebooks and stuff and i
just i would i would love nothing more
than an experience for myself to go to
that comedy museum one day like
hopefully soon and to see your stuff
there would actually be so inspiring and
wonderful what yeah what so what do you
what what do you like the things for
like what does it make you feel it just
makes me feel so connected to that
person and that artist and like oh my
god like they're just like me like
seeing amy winehouse is like her her
little like cheerleaders
yeah
with her little thoughts and i'm like it
just i just feel like wow like they're
just like me and i can be like them and
like we're just all creative and i love
artifacts memorabilia
well you know what it is too it's like
i like giving stuff to people who
appreciate it so i do declutter a lot if
it doesn't go to a family or friend who
i know needs it and it's not just giving
them junk i'll donate it and i know
somebody will need this i also was right
reading this book about i think it's
called always crashing the same car in
l.a and it's this did you hear about
this book triggered no but it sounds
like my oh your history with driving
it's about people who you don't know
their names as household names but how
genius they were and this guy talks
about this one director this woman who
he went to her college and looked up her
artifacts no i'm like why don't i give
some to my college too like what college
would you go to syracuse oh cool so i'm
like you know what like i just but i
never think of myself in the way of
anyone would care of course so you know
what maybe i'll do that i'll approach
both if they say no what's worse that
can happen you gotta give them to us
get ready for eight boxes [ __ ] that's
so funny i can't wait till you're just
like there's boxes taller than you i'm
so excited no there won't be because i'm
going to come see them at the museum oh
great i want to write a book that's
opposite of that book where it's all
people you know about and how useless
they are and how little they've done oh
my god useless [ __ ] wouldn't that be
good the best and speaking of useless
[ __ ] i have not been ever since these
celebrity apprentice i have not been
able to watch reality
tv at all oh it's my favorite wow you
know the background now so you know how
the sausages cook it's so gross and i'm
like i hate people who are famous for
nothing and i think that's what me and
kathy griffin have in common uh because
i think she said in her book if i'm not
mistaken that we don't mind other people
talented being successful like we're
never jealous of that
i [ __ ] hate
people who get rewarded for misbehaving
yeah i think it's disgusting so when i
was on the house the [ __ ] apprentice
with teresa from the housewives the
table flipping god
dude i
she's so stupid
so stupid i hoodwinked her countless
times it's a game you dumb [ __ ]
well i have the best story about her
this story is so [ __ ] great can i
tell you yeah it's so inside okay when
you do the apprentice it's very
stressful so you eat a lot so i didn't
care because i was just fat and it
doesn't matter but those women really
are attached to staying small
so one day my stylist comes in and she
goes oh my god lisa everyone in the
makeup room is saying teresa is probably
pregnant because her stomach
is like very big
so
i said don't worry i'll get to the
[ __ ] bottom of this [ __ ]
so i walk into the little room where
we're all getting mic'd up and i text
and i'm like oh my god teresa's clearly
pregnant because her stomach's super
distended
i sent it to teresa to [ __ ] teresa
do you know though here's why i'm smart
my mind starts going because as you hit
send and you hear this you know
immediately yeah
so two seconds go by and then i go oh
i typed cause i see her look at it and
she's like and i type teresa
the message you just received was
forwarded to you
i can receive that from clay aiken
i said be careful he's on your team
don't trust that shifty homosexual
and poor clay never knew this
and it was so great but you got it i
mean it was that's how tired you are
when you're doing the show that you'll
send a bad text to this person you're
talking about epic save that is iconic
and i've never been able to do a save
like that since lisa thank you so much
for taking the time dude did you do that
start thanking badasses
this was so much fun i feel so grateful
i know this was hard to schedule poor
george he was just going inside
i'm so thrilled that you guys even know
my name all right i have a question more
than that
do you have a price to do stand up no
there's no price because i have enough
money to my i i'm not rich but i have
enough money where i don't have to work
again yeah so i always said somebody
asked me what would it cost to get you
to do a roast again right i said if i
got a million dollars and i could give
it to the animal league of america
because i love it so much because i got
my little doggies there i'm like i do it
for i mean i'd be an [ __ ] to naughty
yeah right like yeah that's a dick move
yeah if they're like here's a million to
your charity then you're like yeah i'm
like starving dogs so yeah but i i don't
know you never know what'll happen but i
can't even imagine a world that i'd want
to do it again yeah but you know you you
never know you know what my only last
dream is like i don't have a bucket list
i have a [ __ ] list because i just do
everything when i want yeah i take
ballroom dancing like twice a week oh
awesome and i'm okay but i could be good
if i tried
my dream is like at 80
i will be
the oldest winner on dancing with the
stars yeah because i'm gonna get so good
in 20 years and some guy some [ __ ]
serbian dancer will be dragging my old
[ __ ] around don't feel sorry for me boom
i win that mirror balls i'm putting it
out there
we actually met the one of the dancers
the sky bell and he danced he's hustlers
he's so hot he's gorgeous
he danced with esther and there's just a
video of esther like being like twirled
by him and then her fiance just
like in the corner like it really is so
funny it is very funny and since wait i
don't believe i know we have to end i
don't believe in necessarily manifesting
i just think you say what you want it's
not going to come to you but you might
as well say it if anyone is listening
my last other dream is
i need to be
uh john crease's ex-wife on cobra kai
that is my favorite show that ever
existed i am johnny lawrence as a human
being and female form-ish female ishmael
so put me on that [ __ ] show yes i
stink as an actor but normally
and i want to manifest both of us on
dancing with the stars and yeah first
place i'll take third i'll be fine
you'll go out first
mickey i'll beat you i'll get kicked off
before they even get to the [ __ ]
they're like uh
that my dancer quits
schmidtkowski for the win i wonder
though if you can learn to dance if you
have no rhythm you can yeah i can't
there's deaf people don't win in that
chat yeah you know i know but they can
feel the ground um lisa everyone is
going to check out your podcast losers
with a dream and you have a book is
there where else no my my huge new york
time non bestseller chocolate please
it's actually something like probably
one of the biggest things i'm proud of
because it's the whole story about my
codependency
my rehab i went to for food and oh my
gosh addiction and i love to read this
it's so deep and it's really funny too
but yeah it was a total non-bestseller
which was my first disappointment in my
life but i learned to deal with it and
also go to lisa lampanelli on the
instagram because i actually answered
dms if you're not hot
wait did they
i feel like bestsellers are cause people
bought them
out isn't there some tricks
but i will tell you this how delusional
i used to be as a comic i would be like
i just was absolutely sure it would be
on the bestseller list because at the
time i was huge and i look and i'm like
huh they must have misplaced it yeah
what are you gonna do but i like that
attitude better than you assuming it's
not gonna be good yeah no i really was
like what's going on it's rigged i tell
you it is rigged it literally is they
buy their own things
bye everybody i love you dude thank you
so much
[Music]
you